let's just read and make sure we've got
everything often what happens is they
give me this ridiculous diagram and then
they pretty much restate everything in a
typical parametric's question in words
so it says the points P with the
coordinates and Q on the corners why are
the parabola X vehicles for a y the
tangents at P and Q intersect at T so
that's why the tangents the chord Q o qo
produced which means we continue it on
meats PT the tangent at K and P KQ is a
right angle looks good so we're pretty
much about everything on that diagram
they don't say P they don't talk about
PL but it's there so we'll just use it
find the gradient of qo and hence show
that P Q equals negative 2 all right so
let's let's have a go with this so I'm
gonna write is that part 1 ok so I'm
gonna say right out required to hmm
gradient of qo question mark I don't
know what it is and P Q equals negative
2 ok so that's where I'm headed q Oh
what's cute oh well
this what this chord here is defined as
from the origin Oh to the point Q and
that's just 2 AQ AQ squared yeah
so the gradient of qo I've got two
points so I'm just going to pop it into
the gradient formula the gradient of Q
equals alright so I guess I'll go rise
over run I'll put a Q squared take away
zero that's the the rise and to a Q take
away zero that's the run and thankfully
you know a lot of stuff is simple and it
cancels out so the zeros from cancel
there's an a on the top of the bottom
which will cancel and there's a Q on the
tombola that'll cancel so that leaves me
I think with Q over - okay done that
wasn't too hard but now
I need to get from here to here so to
find a peek you remember that P and Q
are the gradients at these two points
okay and I think it says hence doesn't
it it says hey and hence show that P Q
equals negative 2 all right so what is
the relationship because this has a P in
it
I've got something with a Q what's the
relationship between this Q o
which is all to do with Q's and P we'll
look at the diagram ok
qo is this guy and P is the gradient of
this line all right
so relationship between them has to do
with that right angle they told us you
see how they connect right so I can say
but Q o is perpendicular to P T right
therefore the gradient of qo times the
gradient of PT that should tell me there
are negative one of you so many times so
I know what qo is it's Q on - I know
what that gradient is the gradient of PT
this says sure this says show so I don't
want to assume even though by definition
the gradient at this point is little P
they said show so I actually want to
demonstrate that so probably the best
way to do it is to say I probably should
have done it earlier actually so I'm
good I'm gonna cheat a little bit I'm
gonna say this is the equation of the
parabola so I can find out the gradient
from that I can say y equals x squared
on for a that means that Y - equals 2x
on for a which is X on a therefore at P
big P Y - will equal to AP on to a
that's just the x coordinate is that
okay so that's what gives me the
lowercase P I would like to just say
that over here but they said show so
that their positions on me - dude it's
not like that was hard either okay so
that's just P equals negative 1 and you
can also see why just imagine right
imagine you're actually Stu doesn't know
how to do this you like I don't know it
but because this result is given you can
sort of guess that has to be paid right
because the next line is literally just
that alright so therefore because this
line is so easy to guess that's why
there's more emphasis on you know you
got you got to show me where that comes
from and that's why this would be here
so I would guess that are basically
there'd be a mark here and a mark sort
of here and you really have to show that
whole lot are you okay with that yeah of
course okay does does little Pete always
refer to the grading of the tangent if
you have the stock standard parabola in
parametric form which is this which
you'll see like 95% of the time then the
short answer is yes in fact that's why
we select P to be what it is because on
the unit circle we have a parameter we
choose it to be cos theta sine theta the
parameters theta and the reason why is
because theater is that angle by
definition right on a parabola we choose
P or Q to be the parameter precisely
because it is the gradient at that point
so that's that's why it's like oh how
convenient that it comes out like now
it's not convenient it's by design but
if they ask you to show it you actually
do have to go through the calculus to do
that okay right have a look about - it
says the chord P oh oh now they talk
about it the chord P o produced meets
the other tangent at L show that PL q is
a right angle so so I'm just going to
put it dollar because I don't actually
know it to be true that's what I want to
prove so I still have a bit of space
over here so I'm going to go part two we
required to prove
that is that P or Q is 90 degrees okay
I always do this particular question
it's because that way I know where I'm
going now
clearly just like I did before all of
this is in coordinate geometry talk so
in order to prove this what I really
want is to prove that the gradient P L
is going to be the negative reciprocal
of this gradient okay so how can I do
that how do I find the gradient of P L
we use the gradient formula again but
different points alright so I can say
the gradient of P L equals two and I'll
use the formula just like I did before
this is rise and this is run PL passes
through the origin as shown on my
diagram so I can keep going just like
before I'm going to end up with this so
p2 so now I know that but what I want to
show is that that multiplied by the
gradient at Q is negative one right so
I'm going to say the gradient of P L
times the gradient of what's the line
I'm comparing it to Q T that's the
tangent what's that equal to okay well
I've got P on two x now it says how many
max isn't it ah okay see how it's one
mark so I'm just gonna at this point I'm
just gonna write Q I'm like look if I
could do it here I don't do it it's
writing exactly the same thing but Q is
the center piece and that one market
signals to me right you get it what's
this this is P Q on to but I know what P
Q is I just showed it in the previous
part so it's negative 2 on to this is
negative 1 but if that is the case QT
I'm there on time therefore P L is
perpendicular
so the angle that I want is 90 degrees
as required okay